some speed limits in Ohio could start
changing daily or even hourly depending
on the traffic our lawmakers passed a
bill that aims to lower the speed limit
when traffic is bad especially during
rush hour officials argued driving
slower will ease congestion but not
everyone is convinced it will work Kris
Van Cleave is above in a state 670 in
Columbus Ohio where the state's first
variable speed limit signs will be
installed Chris good morning good
morning certainly the fastest way
through traffic here in Columbus is in
chopper 10 from our powerhouse WB NS
affiliate here but for everybody down
there on the roads
Ohio is going to try something that
might sound a little crazy they think
they can get you through rush-hour
traffic faster if you go slower drivers
in Columbus Ohio spent on average 41
soul-crushing hours a year stuck in
traffic and the state fears it will only
get worse unless people slow down during
rush hour we believe we can cut
congestion by 30% in cut primary
accidents by 30 to 40 percent jerry ray
is Ohio's director of transportation
he'll oversee the new 48 million dollar
variable speed limit pilot project along
Interstate 670 why use this route myself
and oftentimes I call my wife at five
o'clock or 5:30 and say I am sitting
still the digital speed limit signs will
vary throughout the day from as high as
65 miles per hour when traffic is
running smoothly
235 when the roads are clogged the
shoulder will serve as an extra lane to
relieve traffic jams it's worked in
Europe and several states use it in
limited fashion they're trying to stop
the so-called accordion effect where
drivers speed up to fill in gaps then
have to slow back down but to do that
they're going to have to not only change
the speed limit during rush hour they're
going to have to change how all these
people drive that didn't happen in
Missouri
the show-me state tried variable speed
limits in 2008 only to scrap the project
a few years later drivers did not
believe in it so therefore they didn't
totally abide by it our law enforcement
partners didn't totally believe in that
so they didn't enforce it in Atlanta the
variable speed limit program struggled
to get off the ground as technical
glitches caused the signs to display
conflicting speed limits
Ohio's traffic engineers admit for
drivers to really buy in their commutes
must improve we're confident we can do
it can't build our way out of congestion
we have to make the system that we have
work better
the governor could sign this into law as
early as tomorrow the goal would be to
have the signs up and working on this
stretch by 2018 if it works here in
Columbus the state plans to expand it to
Cincinnati and Cleveland by as early as
2020 dawn it's a smart idea a really
smart idea Chris thank you so much still
hard to think though nor going slower
will actually make you go faster that
it'll actually speed up the community I
like to be in the lane where there's
daylight and yeah I was yeah responsibly
as I can like great great I think we
should go driving with Gayle maybe girl
figure out her style gently I've been
told I have a heavy foot but I'm a very
safe driver officer okay thank you